how's it going everybody its Lauren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things relating to the MCU and
today we have a plot leak for the
Eternals warning not only does this talk
about the plot of the movie but it also
talks about each individual eternals
characteristics including each of their
individual abilities which is a big deal
because a lot of us have been wondering
are they going to give them the same
powers that they have from the comics
which are kind of general powers or are
they going to give them individual
abilities well in this plot leak it
talks about those individual abilities
so we learn about them and we also learn
about how some of the Eternals feel
about humans about the deviance and
about the Celestials it is a pretty
detailed plot leak and description so if
you are trying to avoid any and all
spoilers about the Eternals film you
should click away now oh but I can't
tell you one thing and it's a bit of a
secret if you're still with me we're
gonna dive into this plot leak break it
down overall and then break down each
individual character if you new be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date on the
MCU and so you can into my giveaway for
a chance to win a Xbox one or a ps4 so
this league comes from 4chan and is
believed to be very accurate
mind you 4chan is where the plots for
infinity war were leaked and for
Avengers in game as well all of those
plot leaks ended up being true and based
off of everything that we've learned
about the Eternals this plot leaked
seems to be pretty accurate so it starts
off by saying the Eternals are a group
of super-powered immortal alien warriors
created by the cosmic engineers known as
Celestials they were sent to earth to
protect humankind from the deviants
monstrous creatures also created by the
Celestials that have gone rogue now this
part we already really know we know that
Celestials are going to be a pretty big
part in the Eternals film and they're
going to be making their MCU debut yes
they were in guardians of the galaxy but
that was only really a flashback
so in this film were actually going to
see who the Celestials are it goes on to
say the Eternals arrived on earth in
ancient times and lived among humans
throughout the centuries always keeping
their true nature a secret Suzy who is
played by Jimmy Chan as the Eternals spy
and has psychic powers her mission is to
protect their secret but she enjoys
living among humans and wishes her
family could reveal their existence to
the world
this is pretty accurate two houses he is
in the comics she's a little bit of a
rebel and she enjoys living amongst the
humans
she's pretty independent and most of the
time doesn't really associate with the
other eternals and she doesn't go to a
lot of their gatherings most of the
other Eternals choose to live secluded
from the humans but suzy is the one who
has lived among the humans the most out
of everybody and then of course it talks
about Dana Whitman aka the Black Knight
played by Kit Harington this is one of
her love interests in the comics and it
says Dayne Whitman is an archaeologist
who learns about the Eternals sayers II
is sent to erase his memories but they
instead fall in love
leaving Susie divided between Whitman
and her family
now despite Susie being kind of
rebellious she has always remained true
to the Eternals and has always fought
with them on their side but love does
tend to get in her way and it has been
reported that sayers E and Dayne Whitman
are going to be the stars of the film so
it is going to focus heavily on their
relationship ageac who of course is
going to be played by Salma Hayek is the
leader of the Eternals and has healing
powers she regards the Eternals as her
family particularly because they are not
allowed to have children of their own
now of course a jack in the comics is a
man but they're changing the role for
the movie and in the comics the Eternals
are allowed to have kids in the comics
Ajax is the son of rock R and a MA and
even has a brother named Rx so it seems
like they'll be slightly changing this a
little bit in the movie Icarus who is
going to be played by Richard Madden is
the mightiest of the Eternals and can
manipulate cosmic energy he is loyal and
protective of his family and fiercely
devoted to their mission Tina who is
played by Angelina Jolie is the
deadliest of the Eternals and has
superhuman reflexes
she is brash rebellious and prone to
breaking the rules and carries a great
secret now there's been a lot of talk
about what this secret could possibly be
but everybody seems to believe that it
is a child as it said before in the plot
league the Eternals are seemingly
forbidden from having children and no
doubt it's the Celestials themselves
that have given them this rule so the
big secret is that she could have a
child but who could this child be well
some people suspect that her child could
be drew ik and will talk about him a
little later on in the plot leaked but
put what you think her secret could be
in the comments down below
giggling meshed played
Donnelly is the strongest of the
Eternals and has superhuman strength and
endurance he is sensitive and humorous
despite his massive size and cares
deeply about the others Macari played by
Lauren rid LOF is the Eternals as scout
and has superhuman speed her function is
to travel the world storing knowledge
about the humans and the planet she's
deaf and mute and communicates through
sign language now there are big changes
made to this character because in the
comics this character is a man and is
not deaf or mute and the thing about the
Eternals is they weren't that popular in
their comic book runs and not many
people really know much about the
eternal so they can kind of mess and
change some of these characters which
they've clearly done for Macari next is
Kingo played by Camille Nanjiani and it
says that Kingo is the Eternals
wisecracking fun-loving fighter while
the others have chosen to lead
unassuming lives on earth Kingo has used
his abilities to become a world-famous
bollywood movie star now Camille
Nanjiani got into super good shape to
play this part so kudos to him and this
is pretty much sticking true to his
story in the comics except in the comics
he hails from Japan and is a famous
action Japanese film star so they simply
switched it to Bollywood because
obviously Camille Nanjiani is not
Japanese but Camille actually told us a
little bit about his character in a
recent interview in the interview he
said my character for instance is like
okay we're supposed to keep a low
profile no one should know
so I become a Bollywood movie star
that's my secret identity we're supposed
to keep quiet and I've become the
biggest Bollywood movie star so there's
clearly going to be some humor involved
with his character then we have Fastow's
played by Brian Tyree Henry and he's
said to be the Eternals inventor he's
the most rational of the group and was
once very optimistic but has since lost
his faith in humanity and he is gay now
we've known about this for a very long
time he's going to be Marvel's first
openly gay superhero and it has been
confirmed that he will indeed have a
boyfriend in the movie and then we have
sprite played by Lia McHugh she is the
eternal storyteller and she can create
illusions
despite being permanently trapped in the
body of a child she maintains an upbeat
demeanor and then we have druid played
by Barry Keegan drew aghh is the most
dangerous of the Eternals
can control people's minds particularly
their fears unlike the others he
despises humans and has his own plans
this is who some people are saying could
be Tina's son and again more on him in
just a bit
the movie will span thousands of years
and explore how the Eternals influenced
the history of the MCU before arriving
in modern times when dane whitman
discovers the tomb of the space gods
which is capable of summoning the
Celestials to earth to pass judgment on
humankind the Eternals and the deviants
battle for control of the tomb of the
space gods with Whitman caught in the
crossfire unbeknownst to the Eternals
druid is manipulating both sides to
advance his own agenda so as you can see
here according to this leaked druid is
actually going to be one of the villains
of the movie of course the deviants are
going to be the villains of the movie
but there has to be a primary villain a
single individual and it looks like drew
ik is going to be that villain and a
really big thing to keep in mind is that
it is going to take place post Avengers
Kevin Feige has already come out and
confirmed this since the Eternals are
thousands and thousands of years old and
the Eternals is going to take place over
thousands of years and time in the MCU
people have been asking do the Avengers
know about the Eternals and do the
Eternals know about the Avengers and
everything that has happened do they
know about Loki do they know about
Ultron do they know about Thanos
collecting all of the Infinity stones
and then threatening earth and
performing the blip and then the
Avengers bring in everybody who has
snapped back do they know about all of
this in which Kevin Feige said the
Eternals know about the Avengers but the
Avengers do not know about the Eternals
so we can see how druid might be an
enemy he has seen everything that the
Avengers have done
he has also seen what humanity has done
and since this plot leaked says that he
despises humanity his plan just may be
to summon the Celestials to judge the
humans because he thinks after watching
everything that he's seen all throughout
time thousands of years the Celestials
will come and they will judge the humans
to not be good people
therefore the Celestials would then
destroy Earth or they could deem him
ruler over the earth to get it in shape
and this could very well be the plans
that they are talking about in this plot
leak now also keep in mind that
is a deviant but in the comics he is the
son of two eternals a Lars and soos on
and they even mentioned a Lars and
Avengers infinity war when read school
says Thanos son of a Lars and Thanos is
also thousands of years old as well and
he also has a brother starfox who's an
eternal so if in the Eternals movie
they're going to show multiple different
points in time ancient babylon before
the avengers after the avengers then we
should see San Jose Stoff of his
connections with the Eternals plus him
being a deviant and not to mention he
explained the destruction of Titan the
homeworld of the Eternals in Avengers
infinity war and when they did a
flashback when he used the reality stone
everybody looked normal they didn't look
to be deviance they looked like eternals
so Thanos could very well be considered
an eternal in the movie although he does
have the deviant gene and perhaps Thanos
could play a part in druids plan as well
since Thanos's goal was to wipe out half
of humanity including half of the people
on earth and luckily for us this is
something that will definitely be
finding out soon in the meantime let me
know what do you think about this plot
leak what do you think about each of
these characters attributes and
abilities let me know how you feel about
this in the comments down below don't
forget to subscribe to notifications
turned on and like the video so you can
stay up to date on the MCU and enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 don't forget to follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof